our ideas have the power to change the
world
but you might believe like many people
that your ideas don't matter
that whatever you want for the economy
climate change or human rights you don't
have the power to influence things
well actually your ideas do matter
[Music]
in 2021 the european union launched the
conference on the future of europe an
ambitious and efficient solution that
allows everyone to be heard by europe's
decision makers
it all started on an interactive website
where anyone could share ideas and
solutions on major issues
and people spoke up
posting thousands of ideas and comments
[Music]
meetings were organized and we're not
talking a few meetings in brussels we
are talking about more than 5 000 events
in 27 countries
bringing together
450 000 participants news of the project
spread across europe
panels of citizens were brought together
formed to truly reflect europe's
population
people from across the continent from
all generations and backgrounds the
government interested in our opinion
after debating the most popular ideas
participants took them to the next stage
transforming them into something
stronger a set of recommendations to be
presented and discussed with the eu's
decision makers now it's their task to
turn these ideas into actions
thousands of citizens ideas
200 recommendations for actions
one goal
a better future for europe
[Music]